played overseas thank you very hard I am  breaking a sweat  hi I'm David or yellower and these are  my favorite films my left foot because I  saw that performance by Daniel day-lewis  and it felt like seeing Halley's Comet I  just couldn't believe an actor could do  that Raging Bull that relationship was  played out by Robert De Niro and Joe  Pesci I just think it's one of the most  extraordinary familiar interactions I've  seen the color purple extraordinary film  and I just thought Oprah and particular  was amazing considering was her first  film hail no et I remember seeing that  film and just being taken with the  ability to cinema to show me something I  hadn't seen that I could also relate and  fake fake Lawrence of Arabia the film  just does not age I've seen it so many  times over the years and it just remains  an indisputable  [Music]  [Applause]